hello there today we'll look at llama
Pro Progressive llama with block
expansion this paper takes a llama large
language model specifically a llama 7B
and adds some layers to it now they do
two things in that way first they add
layers in order to teach it new stuff
and second they don't want it to forget
all the stuff it already learned so this
is a method that is going to allow for
some sort of continual learning but
avoid the catastrophic forgetting
problem that's associated with it what
you're going to get out of this is a
model that is kind of picks up the stuff
that you want to add to it in terms of
knowledge so in this particular case you
can see that the Llama the Llama they
originate from now this is llama chat um
but
so the comparison here is a bit weird
but this is llama chat and they compare
it to their instruct uh but what
actually happens is there is the Llama 2
uh base model 7B they take that they
expand it to their llama Pro and then
this one gets like instruction tuned to
become the chat model actually there is
even a llama to instruct right and then
this one also gets instruction tuned to
be from the instruct model uh but in any
way they compare the two resulting
models right here one being just a
regular process and one being the result
of this block expansion route adding in
new data so once you do that uh the
original llama as you can see is pretty
good in these tasks down here but then
falls short on kind of these tasks now
what are these tasks these are tasks
tasks are things like coding these tasks
are math benchmarks and and so on and
what if you for example take a coding
model sure you can take code llama and
that's pretty good at coding as you can
see right here but it falls short in
kind of this domain right here where
it's uh the language understanding
benchmarks abstract reasoning and so on
so the general wisdom being the code the
the data you put into these models will
be reflected in the things they can
eventually do which is quite natural so
what they say is hey look at this we can
now take a data set that contains code
and math specifically their data set
contains code and math and we can take
the red one and we can push that out we
can push the red one out to become also
good at these tasks and that would be
the resulting yellow right here and as
you can see it is still good on the
other tasks now something leads me to
believe that they have chosen the tasks
they list on this wheel pretty carefully
uh so that their thing would make like a
nice
Circle or they've just normalized the uh
they've just normalized the axis to be
so that that's certainly that's probably
it but you can see that wherever the
original llama was lacking um
they can kind of add that by adding data
with this new block expansion and
training and fine-tuning Method without
forgetting the capabilities that the
model has on the old tasks and that's
the whole the whole gist of it how do
they do that as I said they add layers
they freeze everything else and then
they fine-tune the layers they add it
and we'll look at exactly how they do
that so they say the uh humans generally
acquire acire new skills without
compromising the old I don't think
that's necessarily true so if you
have I don't know you you get into it
pretty quickly again let's say you
played an instrument when you were
younger and then you didn't play it for
a whole lot of time you kind of have to
get into it right like you don't know
the songs anymore your finger memory
isn't as good any so but point point
taken and happens a lot more to machine
learning models to forget stuff so they
say they propose a new post pre-training
method for llms what is post
pre-training so you generally have
pre-training um which gives you the
original large language model you do
that on a huge Corpus and then you have
this instruction tuning here right and
as you can see this expansion operation
is between the pre-training and the
instruction tuning so it's sort of
post pre-training that's that's how they
call it
um they say they can effectively
efficiently and effectively improve the
model's knowledge without catastrophic
forgetting they say we experiment on a
corpus of code and math yielding a new
model that is initialized from llama Tob
excelling in general tasks programming
and
Mathematics how do they do it as I said
they simply take so here is a the
architecture of llama 2 with in highest
detail possible uh you have the input
layer right here which gives you token
embeddings for the input and then here
you have the output layer I'm not not
entirely sure honestly output tokens
should probably be should probably
called
embeddings or or embedding weights or
something like this like while we're
talking about model architecture and not
forward propagating signal we should
probably not call these things tokens um
in any case you get some sort of input
embedding and then you pass it just
through uh groups or or blocks of these
Transformer things and these Transformer
blocks usually they have some kind of
attention mechanism some kind of
normalization some kind of Fe forward
layers and so on and then some sort of
residual connection and then there're
may be repeated a bunch of times or have
two feet forward connections or or
whatnot but in essence machine learning
has become in
2024 uh a just let's repeat this thing a
bunch of times and uh shove data into it
that's the whole that that's it that's
what our field has
become so they say hey given that we
have all of these blocks right here how
about how about we kind of take them and
duplicate
them and uh only train the ones that we
have
duplicated what does that mean uh they
so you have layer layer layer layer
layer layer layer layer they say let's
pick some let's pick every third layer
so this one and this one and I guess
that's it and then let's duplicate them
so let's make a copy and insert it here
make a copy insert it here okay now you
would think that that would change the
output signal a lot if you put data in
here you have some duplicated layer some
computation that's being done twice but
there is something going against that
namely usually you have all of these
residual connections right these things
right here uh they usually take the
signal and they add it to the output
signal here and that ensures many things
such as nice data FL nice gradient flow
and so on and you can rely on there
being some sort of residual signal
that's kind of carried over from the
last layer I know this isn't ex entirely
accurate but that's kind of carried over
from the last layer so as long as you
initialize your layer such that the
output is zero right uh you don't change
the output of the whole network because
let's say this is the signal from the
last layer the signal divides into two
branches one is the identity Branch
that's then added with another branch
that goes through your
block so these two are added together
now if you say the out outut of my block
is zero then you can see you have just
the identity function that goes forward
so if you can make your new layer such
that it is it outputs zero initially
then you uh you is at least immediately
after copying you get the new um you get
the the same network okay so that we all
agree
on where it gets a bit controversial I
feel is when they try to make it like
and say okay now when we train we only
going to train the newly added layers so
we're only going to train these layers
that we've added and everything else has
frozen parameters right we just forward
propagate we back prop to these new
layers we'll change the new layers which
will event necessarily move this away
from zero so this block now becomes
active in these new tasks and therefore
will start contributing to the signal
that's also fair right you add
parameters you fine-tune those
parameters people do that with Laura and
whatnot uh so all of that is good now
they claim what this will do is it will
kind of retain the uh old knowledge
while adding in new knowledge and there
is there is where I'm become a bit
skeptical because if you train only with
new data right you permanently add
change the signal it's not like it's not
like the network has an ability to
detect when something is old you know in
the old domain and something is in the
new domain every single signal is routed
through this layer right here for every
single signal that block is probably not
going to be zero anymore and therefore
for every single signal uh there is
going to be a changed output
additionally these people don't train
with a mix of old and new data to kind
of ensure that that would be my guess
right let's say I do something like this
what I would do is I would mix in some
old data maybe they actually have some
as far as I could tell they don't they
only train with the IND domain data
and
thus the network kind of only sees that
new data and can sure it cannot adapt
these old parameters so it can't
technically forget something but it can
configure its new parameters such that
any of the old parameters signal is kind
of distorted because there is no loss in
retaining that data uh and there is no
signal that tells it oh now you need to
kind of have your new layers shut up
because this is clearly in the old
domain so I think this works as long as
the new data is has significant overlap
with the old data for for example I
think uh there there's going to be quite
a bit of code already in the and in math
in the pre-training data of llama and
therefore uh those those overlaps may be
kind of enough but I would be surprised
if this was a general recipe to do more
drastic domain adaptations without
sprinkling in some of the old data there
in any case that's that's essentially
what they do they take every nth layer
they copy it they make sure that it uh
initially outputs zero so they copy and
then they change the necessary weights
to make it output zero and then they
train uh with only those weights active
for training and the rest being
frozen that's essentially it um we'll go
into a little bit more detail on one or
two things around here so yada yada yada
blah blah blah um yeah this this is what
I found funds so they say existing Works
attempted to improve the multifaceted
capability of pre-trained llm with
tailor data recipes while feasible they
require substantial computational
resources and vast amounts of
data for you know keep that in mind that
that's kind of their criticism on the
other work okay we scroll down here so
they we extend Lama Tui oh we pre-train
the expanded blocks on 80 billion token
using open source code and math data for
and math data for
2,830 GPU hours 16 Nvidia h800 for about
days I'm not do h800 exist um I I
thought those were h100s
honestly if if it is I'm not aware of
any GPU that's called an h800 maybe I'm
uh completely ignorant um but if it is
an
h100 using 16 for 7 days is still pretty
massive pretty massive um it's not as
massive as you know full pre-training
runs but you
know it is
um but maybe the all all of those
previous works are even
more uh data and um data and compute
hungry just being said this is not
something you do at home right this
isn't Laura or anything like this uh
where it's easy peasy at domain
adaptation it this is still pretty huge
data pretty huge compute just maybe not
as
huge all right and the criticism on the
other stuff is that it often has
catastrophic forgetting um and decline
in the model's original General
abilities
so here is what they do on the left hand
side you can see a original llama block
and on the right hand side a llama block
after identity copy now this here the
left hand side would be one of the
layers in the original Network and the
right hand side would be so so I think
we made that green right uh the right
hand side would be one of the copy
layers no no I think those are
blue and those are green right so you
copy it
over and then you
change these points here to be zero
which ensures that your output is the
identity so you can see the residual
connection goes here here here so if you
can make sure that this here output zero
uh you're good which means and the best
way to make it zero because it's a feet
forward layer you just make the weight
Matrix zero and that multiplies anything
by zero and that gives you a zero output
the then you have this thing here again
a residual connection and a linear
operation before again you just put it
to zero and that ensures that the entire
thing is just the residual connection at
the initialization obviously during
training you're going to allow all of
these weights in here to to be updated
would be interesting to see what if what
happens if you only allow the uh the
linear things here to be
updated they go a little bit into the
math and the math is rather Superfluous
except for showing you look at this
operation here there is an output weight
Matrix right so you do the whole
attention thing and you put the results
of the attention in here and then you
multiply that by this output weight
Matrix so that's a good point to attack
uh by just setting that to zero likewise
the second component for the feet
forward Network that's some
nonlinearity Shenanigans but ultimately
also multiplied by an output weight
Matrix again a good point to attack and
set that to zero to make sure that
everything is um everything is uh zero
at the at the output so that that is the
whole thing is the identity now is that
a smart idea I'm honestly not super
duper sure it's certainly Smart in that
probably retaining the parameters in the
rest of the layer will already be kind
of good in terms of there are probably
some Primitives in there that can you
can make reuse of on the other hand you
probably don't want that stuff you know
copied in necessarily you prob if in my
mind
in my
mind what this could be much more this
could be more like a few if I had to
design my block it would proba it
probably if I wanted to take this
approach I would probably just design a
bunch of low rank adapters and then just
put push my computation through these
layers here and
back rather
than you know copying over the whole
thing you just if you find tune you just
kind of once they're already trained you
just kind of barely move them away so it
would be interesting to see which of
these parameters actually contribute the
most um would be interesting to see and
as far as I know they haven't done that
but would be interesting to see how much
for example these really diverge over
training and how much these two are
equal so will the L zero initialized
linear layer ultimately just regress to
be the old linear layer with some minor
modifications because it's essentially
the entire signal here is the same up
until this point um or will it somehow
find some completely different uh
forward
propagation yeah the the other the other
point is if you just zero initialize
something you kind of pay zero haha
attention to the scaling that's kind of
in the forward signal so it is um it
could it could lead to kind of
unstable stuff in here or suboptimal
stuff like you start out from zero with
a given signal here that's initialized
at some point then there's probably
something smarter to do there's probably
a smarter way to make the output zero or
to make the whole thing the identity
without just this is like a sledgehammer
you take to the to the weight Matrix you
just be like wow this all goes to zero
there I'm like decently sure there
should be some sort of way to achieve
that that in a in a different
way um usually what one does is one uses
symmetries that exist uh to sort of play
against each other and then always
cancel out but so that they retain a
signal going forward but that might be
tricky with the residual like the
residual connections essentially dictate
that you must that this the output here
must be zero right I'm just wondering if
that's achievable in some different
way but maybe it's entirely pointless
and this works already so in that case
yeah I don't
know it just
seems it seems a bit weird and then
obviously what I mentioned before right
now you have these layers and you
introduce a new one now who says that if
you train this if Act the param if what
you actually want is the parameters to
diverge to learn new stuff right but
then every signal here will be
permanently altered which I doubt that
this this retains the old knowledge
unless there is significant overlap
between old and new in any
case they this this I found this uh
funny because I already told you they
don't expand every single block they
find they only expand you know like
every four four or something like this
ultimately so they make four blocks into
five blocks by copying the last one I
guess but here they start out saying
given a model with blocks such and such
the block expansion incorporates an
identity block after each block in the
original model um ensuring that the
expanded model maintains the same output
for expansion the identity block is
defined as this and I'm like
hm
and here the down below they go into
saying you know this other paper uh had
the idea of initializing the scaling
parameter in the norm modules uh to zero
for the construction of the identity
block however this approach may be not
effective when applied to Lama they go
into why that's not an effective
strategy into llama I decided to look at
that other paper uh and lo and behold
the other paper and you can look that up
that's that's I think it's called um
well you you can see it uh this is the
the URL right here um stage training for
Transformer language models they take a
more General approach to this problem so
they just deal with okay how can we
expand these models kind of
successively while training them um it's
already one or two years
old already well they say epth operators
doubles the number of L layers increases
the number of noning parameters given a
model with layers such and such the
depth operator adds an identity layer
after each layer in the original
model the identity layer is a layer
where the input matches the output
namely this so may maybe they have
essentially how how this new paper came
to be I'm going to guess is they looked
at this paper they were like can we do
this to llama um and they discovered
well it's a bit more tricky than what
they did right here we'll have to do
something else okay let's just set the
the output weights to zero
and yeah and then they might have might
have
um this is not an accusation of
plagiarism or anything like this this is
completely fine in terms of that uh it's
just a little bit funny that uh they uh
they obviously started from the same
starting point and then adapted it to
yourself that that's what that's what
everyone does that's completely fine I
just find it a bit funny and also this
text right here where they try to kind
of Define in numbers ultimately what
they do like their strategy for
expanding layers but their
strategy their strategy is ultimately
just kind of like all right what do you
want well I want to make every fourth
into the into five like okay well every
fourth we copy over that that's fine but
then they try to put some numbers on it
like okay suppose we have an initial
model with L blocks all right check L
blocks where there's already l+ one
blocks right here right uh in their own
example from Z to L that needs to be
expanded into L Prime blocks this
constant here L Prime will never see it
again
never first we partition the original L
blocks into n groups with each group
containing L / n blocks uh that that is
a fair fair division right however how
this n is chosen who
knows never defined right one would
think that it has to do something with
the target number of blocks but this is
just in this very rigorous definition of
how many and where you should copy that
it's a minute detail that gets forgotten
for each group we create identity copies
of the top P blocks and stack them on
top of each group okay so there is now a
number P involved as well and one would
again think that P and N in this case
are probably connected to L Prime but uh
we'll we'll take the top P blocks and
stack them on top of each group so
there's in each group you'll have like
layer layer layer and then you take the
top P blocks let's say that's two and
you kind of do this right you you just
kind of copy them over right here now as
far as I know as far as I can tell their
p is always equal to one and um I don't
think they've done anything else but
it's good it's good that they already
they they they they generalize right
that their Theory generalizes and then
they break it down um we arranged these
blocks in an inter manner to maintain
the structural characteristic of the
Transformer
wait what does it mean we arrange these
blocks by these meaning the top P blocks
but how can they be interleaved when we
stack them on top of the
group like if it's inter believed I
would I would expect it to look like
this I am as confused as you are right
now in anyway all of this is is
completely irrelevant I just thought it
was funny it's completely irrelevant
what you do is you go to any layer you
want you copy it you freeze it you
freeze uh sorry you freeze everything
else right you copy a bunch of layers uh
you freeze everything else and you you
set the initial weights to zero and you
train that's
it um yeah so here they go okay we can
set these matrices to zero and then
that's
it we construct the date set of code and
math expand the number of blocks from 32
to 40 um so there's eight groups where
each groups expand from four blocks to
five blocks thank you good
so here you can see uh the data source
this is math math data and coding data
you can see there's no data of the
original um data set
which so the again H or is this a thing
a h8 h
800s is that a
thing I don't
know here too maybe that's a thing if if
it is if it is and it actually turns out
the h800 is like very small GPU and this
is actually doable at home I'm very
sorry I'm very sorry for my comments um
yeah so the result I've already shown
you uh you can see they're good at code
tasks they're good at um they're good at
language tasks as well so here are
language tasks uh here are code tasks
and their whole point is we can do it
all and without being weak anywhere by
sort of so so we've successfully taken a
llama and expanded its domain of
knowledge into these new
areas again crucially I think the the
thing and yeah here the experiment okay
if we add one block add two block add
three four blocks add eight blocks and
so on um then we get sort of better and
better and better better which is fine
because they add parameters right so
naturally would expect them to get
better in in training so their whole
point in their experiments is uh we are
we are either as good as the old models
or or not much worse um or we are better
in these new domains and sometimes we're
also better in the old domains by the
way so that's the whole thing crucially
and as far as I can see again I might
have missed something right here but
crucially I don't think they've upated
kind of
the the the weird like the questionable
things or the things where I had
questions namely you know how far away
can this new data set be uh to not
muddle up the old data set because if I
think of catastrophic forgetting um I'm
not thinking hey the new task should
have significant overlap with the old
task I'm thinking okay there's something
new and I still want to retain the old
stuff and sure if there's overlap that's
fine but it seems to me right here that
if I only train for long enough on
something like this or if this is
further apart from the original training
data it's not clear to me that the model
retains its original abilities second I
would be really interested what the
specific choice of setting these things
to zero as opposed to anything else has
notably how far the parameters that are
copied diverge from each other and how
far the parameters that are set to zero
converge to the original parameters um
and whether there would be something
smarter to do but all in all um it is
like it all of the thinking and I think
and I feel is not a substitution for a
good empirical evaluation which this lab
has definitely done has and the numbers
I think you know speak to that and that
this seems to be a good recipe and if
that's the case going forward then
that's all all the better uh the code
I've seen on GitHub is said to be coming
soon so we'll we'll see you soon that's
it thank you very much byebye